alle due di notte sento il rumore apro
gli occhi e c'era in camera mia
un mio coinquilino nudo che faceva la
pipì sulla mia mente una reazione
isterica e mi sono messa a ridere come
un idiota ma il giorno dopo ero
terrorizzata non hanno mai capito se
fosse sonnambulo o completamente ubriaco
io non so dovremo montarla cioè questo
quindi ha pisciato alle 2 di notte sui
media phone tipo che si era abbastanza
lungo nel sera spogliato per andare da
lei ciao ragazzi bentornati una puntata
speciale di vita buttata perché perché
l'ultima di questa stagione poi mi
prendono pausa per l'estate riprenderemo
a settembre comunque bando alle ciance
il tema della puntata di oggi è
coinquilini di merda per un tema così
forte ho pensato di chiamare una persona
che ha sempre espresso la sua volontà di
distruggere un format carino e di
rovinarla in tutti i modi un regista un
amico giacomo spa con i ragazzi senti un
po sentiti onorato perché questa è
l'ultima puntata diciamo dell'anno
scolastico se non posso fare danni
esatto così possono dimenticare però che
hanno realizzato la banda torna a casa
dopo le vacanze pasquali trovi il
macello e aprì il mobile sopra la cucina
per bere un bicchiere d'acqua e vedi che
è vuoto
apri gli altri mobili con gli utensili e
anche i tuoi sono spariti e quando le
mandi un messaggio per chiedere
spiegazioni laynes con mi sono
trasferita e dato che nell'anno
massa non c'erano utensili o presso
quello che che mi andava di prendere e
poterlo poi di più ma più che altro il
legale fare una cosa così se tu hai
rubato da una casa non di coinquilini
alla questura intorno che conero avanti
allora ero in spagna a vivere a granada
e ho vissuto l'anno lì e mi trovo molto
male in questi con crescite tremendi che
il rito erano erano spagnoli nell'ultimo
periodo erano ero impazzito perché c'era
un emissione sia veramente troppo schifo
per ora facendo delle cose orribili con
la pelle per questo che praticamente
ogni ogni volta ci faceva il bagno una
vasca da bagno per di pelle morta perché
facevano la muta noi capitolo proposta
sera questa vasca strapiena di pezzetti
di pelle per un anno andare avanti così
qui alla fine quando me ne sono andato
io ho preso un po di cose tipo oggettivo
alcune delle ma tantissime mi piaceva
molto elevata della spagna tipica e non
c'è ed è la mia casa della spagna di
vegas
quindi penso sia legale comunque in
spagna beh posso dirti e legale comunque
il momento in cui mi riempì la vasca e
quel collino di merda è quello che ti
dice non ti preoccupare metto io
le cotolette abbonate a scongelare
element e proprio direttamente
nell'acqua senza un bustino qualcosa lì
attorno a casa vado in cucina e nella
pentola trovo tutta la panatura a galla
questa praticamente la fettina di carne
sprofondata nell'acqua della pentola
scusa ma anche magari potrebbe
scongelare la vasca
comunque di notte dopo averlo viene
fatto così
certo i due anni decide di sputare
nessuno che devo prima rotondi sono
molto parlato con capisco perché quelli
già decide di pubblicare un messaggio
per le dico mai per togliere un divo
aveva assolutamente nulla sulla bacheca
di un'amica in comune da qui ovviamente
solo trono quello che aveva fatto
e quando verranno affronto ed etico che
quello che a [ __ ] anche passibile di
denuncia anche perché aveva una serie di
virus in corsi del titolo di coriano
anche lei mi risponde io non ricordo
tempo cioè figlio questa cosa aspetta
aspetta che continua continua
valerio costantemente
sporco
con considerando che aveva una serie di
arrivo sarà intestinali e quindi fuori
perché c'erano su quella stanza voglio
io sto immaginando il magnum
ma tu non puoi sapere se io mangio il
sugo di te che hai tanti virus tanti
virus poi che cosa mi può provocare
accenna a finire che faccia il sugo
zuppa 2
io se non ho mai avuto coinquilini
quindi realtà sto facendo io l'unica
coinquilina gola muro è stata per questi
ultimi due mesi
una mia amica che mi ospitò tondi nano è
comandato bene perché essendo non è mica
una cifra di male capito questo
sfrattarla molto male da quando adesso
stocco bongo
si è così trovato bene ma noi eravamo
già amici o ad esso convivono si può
dire quindi quando essere un colpo
io conquilino con lui coinquilina
convivo con un ragazzo si è quello
abbiamo già avuto un cartellino il
miglior amico che pongo non lo scettro
grida molto montavo cioè lui era già il
migliore amico da prima quindi abbiamo
fatto il liceo insieme quindi armando
solo con la mostra cup
però siamo tipo in pace perché lui fa
lavapanni ti facciano lavastoviglie cioè
la l'abbandona venisse a liberare la
matrice non si chiama lui dice dalla
bandito dai attivare dal che l'ha
condannato in una doppia quindi il mio
compagno di stanza privata
altri due nostri coinquilini ogni
mattina è entrato nella nostra stanza al
dall apparenza in mano sempre la stessa
canzone sveglia sveglia è già mattina la
tapparella viaggia su vieni in cucina
questo ogni giorno per mario io vorrei
ascoltarla
la mia sveglia è già la mattina la
tapparella di alta cucina
ok impegno sveglia la mattina la
tapparella si alza su vieni inclusiva
che questo è il tempo che maestro allora
[Musica]
è già mattina la campanella si alza su
vieni in cucina bellissima così è come
fa la scritta gli share triste sarebbe
la cover a milano ok
sveglia
e già mattina
[Musica]
bellissima comunque sveglia sveglia e la
nuova itor lista dovremmo regalare quel
mix e rihanna eminem svegliato
[Musica]
si no
la mia coinquilina vita di re della
mattina o meglio fino a quando la si
sveglia trovava che lei si sveglia
lunario 2 del giorno quindi se io faccio
mai arrestato a mezzogiorno storia
quindi mondo intensissimi la macchina
dobbiamo essere tutti tristi e
arrabbiati col mondo esattamente diamo
fastidio ad una persona del web
cara coinquilina di hicks 12 3
[ __ ] crescita va fin dalla
crescita le mani nello schifo
poi ogni volta che usciva dalla doccia
insomma nessuno accappatoio e quindi
nuda e bagnata con le acque attraversa
watt corridoio parti per arrivare con
glielo portata e non asciugava dante poi
se metti una cosa usare i nostri sharp
si basano eccetera
tant'è che una volta unico avanti lei
era frustrata cioè che secondo me è il
mio spero ad una debole tra questo fine
non mi aspetto per niente bellissima
speranza però è ti insegna che deve
essere gentile con il prossimo a me
diceva gesù così pensò ultimo anno che
vivo da sola e ho dovuto cadere casa
generale
perché non vivevo con una rosa di tre
nazionali che è stato almeno l'avvocato
e che per piazzare un fornello a gas che
teneva in camera e le cucinava dice
davvero non sopportava stare con me si
consigliano anche lei mi mette un po
paura accetta anche avresti preso un
forno giorgio perroni coppia non era un
prodotto nato inclina pagana ok anche
una week che aveva potere di parlare con
i cani di cani definiva una mano
coronato una lupa adesso da tantissimi
pericoli
uno in particolare con la tornata a casa
ubriaco e ha vomitato su tutte le
superfici sono in ballo il passato
termoli parla vara michael piace ma non
reagiscano indietro la sciarpina dopo
un'altra mia coinquilina cercando di
utilizzare molto tanto che riceviamo ha
lasciato una scarpa nibile lei con tre
invano prende lasciare una sporta di
monito e la indossa e commentano cha
lance esce lei non era week calerà
satana e deve pamela era la figlia del
demonio l'altro c'è poi devi esser
incarnazioni coco chanel ma lui niente
stavo in cui si stava mangiando qualità
entrambi ago inquilino che inizia a
parlare con noi nel frattempo scoreggia
ma è quando scoreggia fa cercava di
alzare la voce non fare morendo sia
dalla puzza che le risate tranche note
da ieri sta ultimando questa cosa l'ho
smesso di provare il libro in questione
è mia sorella
un giorno ero in balcone e lei per
chiudermi fuori iniziato a passare la
tapparella così io chiara sono in grado
stand tra in più ma la nile scaraventa
la faccia sostenimento non ho capito più
certo facendo il miracolo è lasciato
l'isola esatto e l'espulsione bertrand
la odiavo tua sorella totale cattiva tua
sorelle veramente una pessima persona
tua sorella alta è l'incarnazione di una
lupa nel corpo in una donna e parla con
i cani di la sorella pisce del latte le
altre persone la sorella molto
probabilmente ti piacerebbe anche nella
buchetta della camera nuda
se avete fini questo video di ti
ringrazio
se noi pero siamo arrivati alla fine di
questo video è perché va bene nei minuti
che c'è un po di chiuderlo ti ringrazio
ancora jack per la tua disponibilità
pirlo grazie per la trasmissione ok ha
fatto sim e combatteremo questa salita
un po come vi dicevo all'inizio mi
prenderò un periodo di pausa durante
l'estate sia per godermi un pochino le
vacanze in tranquillità e anche per
portare avanti altri progetti un pochino
top secret
state tranquilli perché non scomparirà
del tutto riprenderò con i video in
autunno e soprattutto continuano a
esistere
gli altri social più semplici e neanche
quindi vi mando un bacio e buonissime
vacanze ciao